[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les leaders du championnat de France de
football les Toulousains maillon foncé
culotte blanche peuvent dire aujourd'hui
qu'ils reviennent de loin après leur
match du Parc des Princes contre le
Racing Club de Paris le match nul qu'ils
ont obtenu est extrêmement flatteur pour
prière mi-t ass équilibr malgré quelques
occasions de but pour le Racing comme
celleci g
par mi-emp les Parisiens prent
l'avantage 1
à0 et puis plus rien le racingille un pe
trop Toulouse bien timidement cependant
en profite pour relancer ses
attaques les 300 spectateur cro la
victoire du Racing lorsà 2 minutes de la
fin du match seuit un coup de théâtre
penalty pour Toulouse d'ailleurs très
justifié boky le tire à côté le goal
parisien a plongé trop tôt dit l'arbitre
il faut tirer une nouvelle fois le
penalty mais personne n'est d'accord
avec lui Toulouse profite de l'occasion
match nul un match nul tiré par les
cheveux et qui provoque une belle
tempête dans les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tribunes le général de Gaulle sera dans
l'histoire le premier chef d'État
français à avoir rendu visite à
l'Iran le chat et l'impératrice faradiba
ont accueilli le président et l'on
conduit au palais du Golestan dans la
salle des diamants où avait lieu un
dîner d'appara à l'issue de ce dîner le
général de Gaulle devait déclarer à nos
deux peuples libres la liberté paraît
d'autant plus précieuse qu'elle se
trouve actuellement menacée il y a là un
lien puissant et permanent
entre les entretiens politiques tourisme
et curiosité trouvèrent leur place c'est
ainsi que derrière d'énormes portes
d'aciers le souverain fit découvrir à
ses hôtes le trésor féérique des mil et
une nuits du du trône des pan aux
couronnes
impériales et à ce globe terrestre où
chaque capitale est un
diamant puis ce fut percépce la
métropole construite par Darius et
détruite par Alexandre dont les ruines
monumentales étonnent
toujours et ispah la ville des Roses et
là comme àiras devant l'enthousiasme des
foules le général de Gaulle a pu mesurer
la Pée voyage qui marquait après une
absence de plusieurs années le retour de
la France dans le
[Applaudissements]
MoyenOrient diverses manifestations ont
salué le départ du chancelier ad à hanre
d'abord ce fut la revue de cette
bundosphè créé par Ad en
1954is
à congé de celui qui porta pendant 14
ans le destin de l'Allemagne et qui lui
restitua sa place dans le cercle des
grandes
nations herart lui succède herart qui
fut son ministre de l'économie et qui
fit d'une Allemagne ruinée une Allemagne
en pleine
[Musique]
prospérité le chef du gouvernement
anglais monsieur mcman a quitté le
pouvoir qu'il détenait depuis
1957 sur son conseil la reine ellisabeth
a choisi pour lui succéder à Downing
Street le ministre des Affaires
étrangères Lord hum qui devra renoncer à
son titre pour rentrer à la Chambre des
communes Premier ministre et chef du
Parti conservateur sur Alexander Douglas
hum se trouve devant des problèmes
[Musique]
difficiles au milieu des sables rien ne
marque la frontière au confin
algéro-marocain mais pour cette ligne
sans vrai dessin algérien et marocains
s'affrontent deux postes perdus dans le
désert assibida et tinjub ont été
l'enjeu d'une lutte sévère occupée tour
à tour par les deux
adversaires finalement les forces
marocaines ont repris ces deux positions
avec leurs point d'eau et leur
Palmera la rencontre avait fait une
dizaine de morts et des
blessés à Marrakech Monsieur Mohamed
Yazid venu au nom du président Ben Bella
s'entretenir avec le roi du Maroc de ce
douloureux problème reprenait être
arrivé à un accord le chemin d'Alger
d'Alger ou devant une foule survoltée
réunie sur le forum le président
Benbella appelait aux armes le peuple
algérien et décrétait la mobilisation de
tous les anciens
Jun pendant ce temps à Marrakech le roi
Hassan 2 recevait la visite du
nguscier au cours de cette visite prévue
depuis longtemps mais dont les
circonstances allaient changer le sens
le néus allait en effet chercher à faire
avancer le dialogue algéro-marocain vers
une solution de paix
partout en Algérie la mobilisation
s'opérait les anciens Jun répondant à
l'appel de Benbella repren du service et
sur la route de colombéchar Centre de
rassemblement des forces algériennes les
renforts commen à monter vers cette
frontière imprécise qui n'est peut-être
qu'un prétexte pour lequel s'affronte
deux idées politiques et deux façons de
concevoir l'avenir du
Magreb
les besoins domestiques comme ceux de
l'industrie imposent à la production
électrique de doubler tous les 10 ans en
effet la France consommit en 1952 41
milliards de kWh elle en a consommé 83
en
1962 et c'est une véritable course
contre la montre que traduit la carte de
France de l'équipement en 10 ans
barrages et centrales thermiqu ont dû
constamment précéder une demande sans
cesse grandissante le survol de la seule
vallée du Drac dans les Alpes est à ce
titre éloquant depuis 1930 où fut édifié
le barrage du SAU cette Vallé n'a cessé
de se hérisser d'ouvrage nouveaux aux
installations de Cordéac ont succédé
celle d'un 3è barrage celui de
Saint-Pierre Coget enfin un 4è est entré
en service le plus important
montén la retenue de 240 millions de
mètres cbes autorisera une production
totale de 430 millions de kWh lorsque
deux nouveaux groupes seront ajoutés aux
deux groupes déjà en
service la centrale thermique de ver
dans la région parisienne illustre un
autre aspect de cette progression qui
exige des usines de plus en plus
puissant ver du reste détient un record
européen avec un groupe de 250000 kW à
une seule ligne d'arbre 41 milliard de
kWh en 1952 83 1962 et l'électricité de
France se prépare à en produire 170
milliards en
[Musique]
c'est seulement maintenant que l'on peut
se faire une idée de la violence de cet
ouragan auquel les météorologistes
donnèrent le nom de Flora de Cuba nous
parviennent les images dramatiques de
ces journées qui virent disparaître des
milliers d'habitations anéantir des
milliers d'hectctares de plantation et
provoquer plus de 1000
morts pendant 5 jours le vent et la
pluie se sont acharné sur l'île
l'eau inexorablement s'est répandue sur
les terres basses s'étalant comme dans
la province d'Oriente sur un front de 40
à 80 km FID Castro s'est mis à la tête
des secours organisant lui-même les
convois de sauvetage c'est d'ailleurs au
cours d'une de ses mission que son
véhicule amphibie faillit sombrer en
traversant le cours tumultueux de la
rivière
[Musique]
larora partout le même spectacle
tragique camion jet par le FL hors de la
route sur lesquelles se sont réfugiés
des groupes surpris par
l'inondation plantation hier florissante
aujourd'hui couverte par un flot
boueux les hélicoptères ont été lancés à
la recherche des rescapés repérant les
groupes en détresse et secourant les
isolés car sur cette immense désert
liquide des hommes vivent encore au pris
avec la faim la soif et la peur
Cuba offre le spectacle d'un immense
désastre culture submergé troupeaux
foudroyés dans leur fuite maisons
effondrées communications
coupées 1000 morts et 100000 sans abris
et il faut leur ajouter les victimes
d'Haïti de la Martinique de la Jamaïque
celle de toutes ces Antilles ravagé par
l'ouragan Flora des milliers de morts et
des milliers de pauvres gens jetés
soudain au cœur du malheur des visages
creusés par une aventure inhumaine et à
qui il ne reste plus vraiment plus que
leurs yeux pour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pleurer